last question today hey David why are
Americans more religious than Europeans
two main pillars of reasoning that I
believe explain why Americans today are
more religious than Europeans first of
all some of the early settlers of the
United States of America came to the
United States of America and left the
countries of their origin in in many
cases in the UK but also people from the
Netherlands Germans and others they came
here because they wanted the freedom to
practice their religion unfettered by
the religious de facto status quos of
their countries in Europe so by
definition when you have a country that
starts with the idea of being able to
practice religion unfettered that may
lead to a more religious population now
of course it's been many hundreds of
years so then the the sort of secondary
question would be why has the United
States not become less religious at the
same speed that Europe has well I would
argue that Europe has become less
religious in some places but not in
others there are still parts of Europe
and communities in Europe that are still
quite religious the difference is that
Europe has drawn a much harder line when
it comes to separation of church and
state secularism the idea that religion
simply has no place in the sort of
government and public sphere in the
United States you have even today a
significant portion of Republicans in
the House and Senate who are quote
Christians some of them are Catholics
some of them are evangelicals Baptist
all sorts of different sects who kind of
believe in separation of church and
state but they still talk about the
morality they get from the Bible in
terms of the raw position to abortion or
their opposition to LGBT rights or
whatever the case may be so the lack of
a firewall between church and state in
the United States has fostered the
country remaining more religious than
lots of
on trees in Europe have you you talked
about some of the historical reasoning
yeah it also has to do with the new
frontier you know that America has
experienced over the past 200 years or
so like there were even people who would
leave Massachusetts and like the pilgrim
colony because they wanted to start
religious movements of their own like
Roger Williams in Rhode Island or even
more recently Mormons in Utah and so
just like having that space to venture
out and start your own thing yeah I
think that helps like at a grassroots
level develop your own religion I think
you're right and in the background we
can't ignore that scientific and
mathematical proficiency is inversely
correlated with religiosity okay and if
you've been following the education
crisis that the United States is facing
you would know that we are being rapidly
overtaken by many other countries in
math and science I believe it would be
borne out and of course this is the
country we have so there's no way to
really a be test that we can compare to
other countries but ever every country
is different if the United States was
doing better in math and science and
everybody had a more thorough
understanding of not only math and
science but critical thinking and
philosophy from an early age you would
probably see religious belief decay more
quickly than we're seeing it decay well
that's because all those professors are
indoctrinating gorsh children with their
atheist garbage no doubt
of course yeah it's a complete
conspiracy but it would work and last
thing the United States is becoming less
and less religious over time let's not
forget that it's just not becoming less
and less religious as quickly as other
countries particularly countries in
Europe are but the u.s. is becoming less
religious and I see nothing at this
point that's going to reverse that trend
thank you for your questions we have a
great bonus show planned for you today
access the bonus show two options number
one become a member at wwe.com option
number two become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
give you instant access to the
world-famous bonus show which is coming
up right after the show